قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان القوه
الروسيه كشفت قصفها على المناطق الماهوله
بالسكان في مقاطعه تاخيرسون وزبرجيا
جنوبيه البلاد
واضافت الهيئه ان اكثر من 20 بلده في زبرج
يتعرضت للقصف المدفعي خلال ساعات الماضيه
اضافه الى استهداف القرى الواقعه على خط
التماس في خرسا
معنى الان من خرسه الجنوبي اوكرانيا مراسل
الجزيره تامر حسني تامر ما الذي يمكن ان
يضاف حول تطورات الميدانيه وانت في ذات
النطاق
بالفعل ازدهار القصف يتواصل على مقاطعه
خيرسون عموم المقاطعه خلال الدقائق
الاخيره السلطات الاوكرانيه المحليه هناك
تتحدث عن عشرات
على عشرات من الهجوم الروسي المتواصل قصف
متواصل عشرات الضربات الروسيه باتجاه قلب
المدينه خيلسون بالاضافه الى القرى
والبلدات الواقعه على خطا التماس السلطات
ايضا تقول بان القصب يجري بها المدفعيه
الثقيله بقذائف الهاون بمنظمات صاروخيه
ويستهدف بشكل اساسي البنيه التحتيه
المدنيه بالاضافه الى القرى الواقعه على
خطوط التماس بالمناسبه هذه الكره كثير
منها تم افراغه من السكان على واقع احتدام
المعارك بين القوات الروسيه والاكرانيه
لاسيه بالمدفعيه الثقيله نحن انجزنا
تقريرا من هناك تطرق الى تطورات القتال
عند نهر دنيبر وكانت القوات الاوكرانيه قل
بانها تكثف من قصفها لمواقع تمركز القوات
الروسيه عند الضفه الشرقيه من النهر تتحدث
عن مزيد من التعزيزات
الروسيه التي تصل تباعا الى الضفه الشرقيه
من غير سون وتقول بان هذه التعزيزات هي
تعزيزات عسكريه وتتضمن ايضا وصول مجموعات
من الافراد الى اسناد القوات المتواجده
وذلك على واقع القصف الاوكراني المتواصل
وتتحدث اوكراني عن قصها ايضا لخطوط
الامداد التي تصل من خلالها
اللوجستيات والدعم عبر شبه جزيره القرموها
بالتاكيد التطورات ايضا متلاحقه متسارعه
في مقاطعه جنوب البلاد ايضا التي تتعرض
لقصف متواصل من قبل القوات الروسيه ما على
المناطق المهوله بالسكان وفقا لبيان هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه الذي ظهر صباح هذا
اليوم تحدث عن قصه اكثر من 20 منطقه وبلده
وقريه همم في المناطق التي تسيطر عليها
القوات الاوكرانيه وهذا القصف الروسي في
الحقيقه ازدهار جاء بعد ساعات فقط من نفي
القوات الاوكرانيه ان تكون مواقعها او
المواقع التي تسيطر عليها في ايزاباروجيا
قد وقعت في قبضه القوات الروسيه تحدثت
باقتضاض فقط وقالت بان القوات الاوكرانيه
تمكنت من استعاده بعض المواقع التي وقعت
في قبضه القوات الروسيه وان الهجوم الواسع
على مواقع سيطرتها من قبل القوات الروسيه
توقف بشكل نهائي وانها تكثف من ضرباتها
الصاروخيه والمدفعيه نهايه
المقاطعه شكرا
يا مراسل الجزيره كامل